and on the mound for the mariners
tonight
logan gilbert fresh off that
outstanding outing last time out in
cleveland
a swing animus for strike three logan
gilbert strikes out the lead on batter
randy arose arena
for the tampa bay ray's lefty josh
fleming will be making the start here
tonight his sixth
start 12th overall appearance the record
lot of decisions
yeah the comebacker
little underhanded toss into one two
three
we go to the second
no score
that's a shot right back through the
middle
right over the pitching rubber it seemed
and meadows is aboard to lead off the
second inning
oh good pitch
strike three
held on by murph one down
here's joey wendell runner on the move
the pitch hit on the ground that's fair
up the left field line
meadows will go to third they're going
to wave him around and the throw will be
cut off the rays have a run
as meadow scores from first wendell got
that ball just fair for two bases
the ball up the left field side
first and third for the raise for mike
zenino see the ball hit it the one-two
pitch swinging a high fly ball into the
left i think it's deep enough to his
left is shed long junior giving way to
the center fielder fraley the catch is
made tagging at third and on his way
home as joey wendell cenino gets the run
batted in and the rays have a two
nothing lead in seattle
that's hit on the button it's going to
get down seeger
hard
digging going for two got to get there
he does a lead off double for kyle
seeger here in the second inning
payoff here to tell murphy
hit it through the six-hole seeger will
have to hold danny will stop him right
there murph makes a big turn at first so
here come the mariners
brings up jake bowers he has swung to
bat well in his nine games with the
mountains 3 43 a homer four runs batted
in
off the fifth the other way the theme
continues from last night jake bowers
with an rbi single mariners on the board
three consecutive hits here in the
second inning
knocking the door it's opportunity for
mr fraley and the mariners down 2-1
bases loaded nobody out
1-2
he is out on strikes
that's a very big strikeout big out and
a strikeout the type about even bigger
[Applause]
and he got him boy that's
a great job by fleming right there
that's impressive this is still a very
tough out with crawford coming up got
him to ground a second to open the first
inning and now batting with two out of
the bases loaded
that's hit well whitefield
that's gone a grand slam for j.p clovers
and the mariners
they're taking a big lead here in the
second inning
finally with two outs they cash in by
two mariners happy juneteenth jp
two and two to rosarina
swinging in a mess he struck him out
again third k tonight for gilbert
infield straight up for yandy diaz here
comes the 02.
swinging in this got him
hogan gilbert nice one two three inning
with a couple of k's gives him four in
the early going got a five two lead
just won his last two starts in the big
leagues the wind-up and the 3-2 pitch
swaying and abyss at a pitch up and in
he strikes on meadows
wow here's a drive
left field
oh wow the glove of meadows demo digging
for second he's in with a dive a
leave-off devil in the fourth inning
there's [ __ ] long struck out on the o2
pitch with the bases loaded for the
second out in that second inning
to chopper infield and throw to the
plate
will be in time
so the rays with the infield in
waltz goes to zanino to cut down dylan
moore former mariner and now ray
mike zanino leading it off
that's a shot into left field well
tagged out of here
home run into the bullpen off the bat of
mike zanino
that's number 14. so the raise on the
board in the fifth that will make it
five to three
gilbert
breaking up some more strikeouts got a
5-3 lead
powers out on strikes two men left went
through five it's a two-run game 5-3
seattle
here is manuel margot who is struck out
and grounded the first hillary for two
that's a long one back into deep left
that's gonna carry and go home run off
the bat of manuel margot margot belch
his seventh home run
and that will make it a one-run game
on the ground right side and that's
wendell again
three ground ball outs in the sixth
inning
we're gonna go to the seventh in a one
run game five four seattle
[Applause]
got him looking
[Applause]
oh two
tenth
tampa bay ray to k tonight two down in
the eighth
swing in a miss to everybody on in a
one-run game brandon lau will pinch it
for taylor walls
there's a high-fly ball off the bat of
lao this might get it done that baby is
out of here
home run a pinch hit home run for lau
and the raves have tied this game with
two outs in the ninth
jp crawford will start at second base
mitch henniger will stand in
line drive left then here comes j.p
they're waving him there's the throw jp
he's in vince
wins it with a basement for the mariners
and they take the first three games
against the defending american league
champion tampa bay rays